der ausbruch des vesuv 79 nach christus
war eine unglaubliche tragödie doch der
vulkanausbruch führte nicht nur zu
giftigen aschewolken und glut lawinen
die den menschen einen furchtbaren tod
brachten der vesuv hat sogar
menschliches gehirn zu achtung glas
schmelzen lassen wort krieg science
fiction gibt es spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
man muss sich das mal vorstellen wie das
horrorszenario schlechthin quasi die
hölle am golf von neapel erst ein
zittern der erde bebte denn die
gewaltigen lavamassen des vesuv machten
druck von unten straßen und häuser
bekamen risse dächer fielen zusammen und
der boden unter den siedlungen
verflüssigte sich die menschen wurden
unter ihren eigenen häusern begraben es
roch nach verfaulten eiern dafür sorgten
die auf quellen gase schwefel und
kohlendioxid plötzlich löste sich der
gesteins topfen im schlot des vulkans
und das glühende magma schwarz hervor
die säule aus asche flüssigem gestein
und gas war bis zu 30 kilometer hoch der
großteil der menschen erstickte an den
giftigen aschewolken und sofort schossen
pyroklastischen ströme dem vulkan
hinunter in der fachsprache sind damit
glut aschewolken gemeint sie rasten mit
enormen geschwindigkeiten dem vulkan
hänge herab und verdampfen die menschen
dabei ein unglaublich grausamer tod
wahrscheinlich wenn man ihn von außen
betrachtet die opfer selbst haben davon
kaum etwas mitbekommen dass ging in
sekundenbruchteilen
doch der vesuv stellte noch mehr mit den
menschen an ein forschungsteam hat diese
neue erkenntnis jetzt durch einen
möglichen fund gewonnen konkret haben
neue untersuchungen an einer leiche aus
heracleum offenbart dass sich das gehirn
des damals etwa 25 jahre alten mannes
durch die extrem hohen temperaturen in
glas verwandelt haben muss dazu einer
der beteiligten wissenschaftler bvj ohne
bis heute wurden noch nie verglaste
reste eines gehirns gefunden
bei ihren untersuchungen hatten die
fachleute in dem opfer einen schwarzen
glänzenden brocken entdeckt diesen
konnten sie dann als überbleibsel des
menschlichen hirngewebe ist
identifizieren dass durch die hitze
umgewandelt
worden war bestandteile die nicht aus
der asche wolke stammen können wie
beispielsweise proteine lassen diese
herleitung zu denn proteine sind
charakteristische bestandteile von
gehirn auch mit dabei fettsäuren wie man
sehen haaren findet all das lässt nach
ansicht des forschungsteams darauf
schließen dass es sich um überbleibsel
menschlichen hirngewebes handelt im
selben raum wie die leiche wurden auch
verkohlte holzreste aufgespürt diese
zeigen dass die verglasung des gehirns
bei unglaublich hohen temperaturen stark
von namos die chemische reaktion kam
zustande durch luft und asche mit
temperaturen von bis zu 500 20 grad
celsius darauf folgte wohl eine schnelle
abkühlung was offensichtlich zu dieser
ungewöhnlichen glas bildung geführt hat
die leiche des damals 25 jahre alten
mannes mit dem jetzt identifizierten
gläsernen gehirn wurde übrigens bereits
vor 60 jahren und 60 in herculaneum
gefunden man geht davon aus dass es sich
um den hausmeister des priesterkollegs
kollegium august ali um handelt er hatte
sich wohl mit dem kopf nach unten auf
ein holzbrett gelegt und die nahende
katastrophe erwartet katastrophe durch
supervulkan hat die nasa die lösung
anklicken hier anschauen und klicks um
science-fiction abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran